now and Christmas just really went
together now love Christmas from
September onwards that was it you know
it was Christmas all the way count down
how many sleeps and yeah Christmas was
just Nels thing
Nell Jones was 14 when she was killed in
the Manchester Arena terror attack for
her family facing Christmas is tough
it's difficult there's a part of the
family missing and there always will be
part of the family missing you've just
got to deal with it I always have to you
know buy a things
I mean I've bought a Christmas present
again and I've still bought baubles and
things for her but you just makes me
feel like I'm kind of doing something
for her and she's kind of still around I
like to think she's somewhere thinking
you know thanks mom yeah so well Harry
Potter you see they all loved Harry
Potter didn't change this year the
family have bought hundreds of presents
in Nels memory for children who might
otherwise have had nothing it was
poignant because you know especially the
girls stuff it was just like well Nell
would look back so you know I knew what
to get really 2,000 pounds raised by the
remembering Nell foundation paid for the
gifts they've donated to the wood Street
mission charity in Manchester just be
nice to think that they're going to open
them on Christmas Day and and you know
hopefully be a smile there so the Lego
in particular he's always really really
popular
what and they remember me now foundation
and those family have gotten in donating
all of those presents tools is is giving
children a special Christmas giving them
something to open on Christmas Day like
any other child
and we think it's wonderful Vanilla's
family christmas is now about memories
you know ever could swap places with a
reward but I can't so you know I'll just
I'll just get used to it
yeah but you know she was loved so much
I mean nobody could have loved her more
than we did you know she was she was a
lovely girl I'm very proud to say she
was ours yeah yeah her family hope
they've helped other children to smile
like Nell did at her favorite time of
year
Becky Johnson Sky News Manchester